only on CBS this morning our lead
national correspondent David beg no was
allowed inside a crucial power plant in
Puerto Rico that was severely damaged by
this week's earthquakes the power
situation on the island is critical
following a 6.4 magnitude earthquake
Tuesday 600,000 customers do have power
at the moment but around 900,000 people
about a third of the population are
still in the dark
David beg no is live outside the plant
in Gua Nia along the southern coast
David how did you manage to get inside
well Anthony we came and sat outside the
plant for four and a half hours
yesterday waiting for the head of the
power authority to leave and as he drove
out this gate I asked for an interview
and he said yes and when the interview
was over I asked him to go inside and
actually see the damage he said yes to
both of them and it was important
because the people of Puerto Rico do not
trust the folks who run the power
authority that is the truth you're not
only about to see the damage and hear
what they told us you're gonna hear two
different stories between the man who
runs the power authority and the man who
runs the plant who were in disagreement
about when they're gonna get this plant
back up and running you can see that
most of the structure is compromised our
guide was on Hill Perez operations
manager here at Costa soar he showed us
the damage starting with these tanks
which are used to clean water it is he
says the first step in the energy
generation process you can see this tank
just knocked over and it it did it all
the way down the line yes sir so again
without this you can't provide power we
cannot even think to provide power to
anybody from here Perez says the water
is sent to even larger tanks which have
also been damaged a fracture in the
meter painting the base of the tank just
this morning we were invited back inside
the plant they wanted to show us the
control room you can see the damage
inside it's not safe for people to work
here they also gave us photos of a
damaged turbine the reality is with
coastal sort of not generating any
energy hundreds of thousands of people
will be without power what's the reality
do you think people are gonna have to
sort of get used to having power maybe
half
and not having it the other half we're
going to walk 24 hours around the clock
I hear you and a lot of people are happy
to hear that but be as realistic with me
as possible or less than a month compare
that to what the head of Puerto Rico's
Electric Power Authority says Jose Ortiz
the CEO if I faith it would be out for
probably over a year how much of this is
earthquake related or how much is it
just old equipment that hasn't been
cared for and updated it's both really
you know to be honest those plans were
have over 60 years basically imagine you
have a taxi 60 years old and you are
required to run that 24/7 said you know
it's that's the kind of business we're
running when folks here in Puerto Rico
heard Jose Ortiz say it could take a
year to get coastal soil back up and
running
there was a trending hashtag on Twitter
Jose Ortiz renunciant for him to resign
listen this is what he told me he said
they're asking FEMA to bring in a 500
megawatt generator to go ahead and get
this place back up and running when FEMA
heard him say that in our interview Gail
they reached out to me and said we have
not agreed to do that and we cannot do
that under the current emergency
declaration that Puerto Rico is
operating under they need a major
disaster declaration and as of now the
governor has not requested it and the
president has not signed it Wow David
first Bravo to you very interesting
information that you have and you're
literally standing outside and asked to
come in and they say okay come in that's
amazing they did and again this morning
they came back to us and said come back
in we want to show you some more so we
wanted the people here on the island to
see exactly what the damage is all right
David Beck no thank you great reporting
as always
you